President Obama is on a three-day
fundraising tour on the west coast
starting today going on for the next two
days and he uh is getting a lot of heat
from people because I hope you guys know
about this but there are some problems
in the Middle East have you heard about
that there's some situation going on
with Gaza and Israel out if you heard
about the plane and Russia and Ukraine
we have this border thing and Rick Perry
sending troops or something down there
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on in the
world right now and our second term
president is doing three days of
fundraising and apparently just bought a
house in Palm Springs to retire in after
his presidency she's got a lot of crap
about this and what we've got a little
bit more info about some of the stuff
he's doing over the next couple days so
based on descriptions of Obama's
fundraisers from Democratic officials he
could raise over six million dollars
during the trip which comes at the same
time as I said of the Israeli ground
invasion in Gaza and all this stuff with
the jetliner over Ukraine so it's sort
of an estimate that he could raise
around six million it could be a little
bit less could be a little bit more but
forgetting the numbers like is this bad
optics is this just bad like what's he
do this is a second term guy he's not
even raising the money for himself he's
raising it for the party this just seems
bad to me I mean it does come across as
in poor taste but at the same time it's
not as though I'm firmly convinced there
would have been doing anything anyway
about the situation's anywhere else in
the world yeah had he not been
fundraising so it's a great cover for
not wanting to do anything so there's
that right so Jimmy we talked about
money in politics a lot is this just
like is just par for the course right
this is just what they do no matter
what's gone no I think this is a
legitimate criticism because if you
remember uh when george bush was
president he didn't fundraise and he fix
katrina like that and a ray wasn't five
he wouldn't so that's how Iraq got fixed
so yeah so apparently if Barack Obama
wasn't out here raising funds that he
could fix everything right just like if
this he could fix everything if you just
had a third term it is a she can't get
fixed now but as with other things were
different everything we get fixed so
that's sort of a defense of what's going
on here from them correctly Barack Obama
fundraising I think it's uh well overall
it's horrible that we have a system
where the
president needs the fund raised in the
middle of a crisis yes overall we need
to change that system I thought Barack
Obama was going to be a bigger force to
change that system turns out he's not
he's just one of the boys so that's I
guess the sad part we all fought hope
and change like we're gonna really
change the system and that clearly so
yes he still has phones as they as they
keep saying the press everything you
keep saying he's got phones he's got the
internet he can call Putin and he can
call Netanyahu but still just doesn't it
just doesn't sit with me well and I
guess my mom can I just feel like you
know what dude three days of fundraising
right now really I get you know oh I'm
sorry no no at the end of the day I
comes back to there's never been a
strong policy i don't believe at least
historically for Pete for presidents
doing something about international
crises until it's so far escalated that
it's like if you don't get involved now
you're a complete [ __ ] so the policy
we need is that we need this [ __ ] to all
get worse it gets me like the bottom of
the freakin barrel and then oh we're
gonna step in now yeah yeah yeah
depending on what time it wasn't on well
you don't want to work with it it could
have hit it right now let's look a
little bit more about who he's meeting
on these fundraisers his first office at
the home of developer Bruce bloom to
benefit the DNC he's gonna headline an
event hosted by jim senegal who's a
co-founder of costco which will benefit
the Senate Majority PAC as we all love
these packs and he'll attend fundraisers
at the homes of scandal creator and the
CEO of live nation also to benefit the
DNC yeah power to the people power to
the people Democrats all about the
people right but that's what they say
right there supposed to be more for the
people so if this was a Republican
President Jimmy wouldn't you be angry
yes I would because I'm big hypocrite no
as you can admit it that's all that
matters I mean I I don't know um I
really did I did I did criticize George
Bush for being at the fundraiser during
Katrina I certainly did do that but this
is a there was a crisis happening in
America right these are crises is
happening in other countries which he
really has limited he can't really do
anything about them anyway and I say
about the border if there really is a
crisis at the border how
can we have a bomb the border good point
thank you good point uni we needed to
think on our side their second there's a
little there was a little thinking there
um is it is it clear to you guys the
beam president is sort of just not what
we thought it was I think that the more
I watch what of this presidency has been
like I like the guy he plays basketball
he seems cool i'd like to hang out with
them but the more that I just watch
what's going on here just seems me the
president no matter who it is it's the
same [ __ ] if it were this was a
Republican it would be the same like the
guy would be doing the same thing and
just not much changes it's for me proof
that the system itself is broken yes the
system itself is broken because if you
can take someone that you have faith in
while they're campaigning and you can
see I can see the change is going to
happen and this is gonna be amazing and
it's gonna be so different and then fast
forward four or seven or however many
years in and it's the same [ __ ] on a
different day or same [ __ ] different
president yeah it got you get you
thinking that it's a system that is so
bogged down with the politicking of
being president that you can no longer
effectively do your job i think is hit
it that's why i'm so disappointed with
him because we all had these high hopes
i voted for the guy twice so that's why
i'm so disappointed cuz if this had just
been some other guy would have been like
yeah okay it's just another guy doing
the same old [ __ ] but because of the
hope and change even the second time i
was still like he's gonna be a little
better he won't be constrained by an
election and yet he still doing the same
[ __ ] bring us home Jimmy door but what I
like to say is that we get a choice in
America and politicians rights because
when Romney ran against Obama if Romney
would have won we would have got
Romneycare but Obama won so we got
Romneycare we get a choice in America
your country is just not that into you
which you can read all about of the new
book there you go Jimmy doors new book
your country's just not that into you
he's got a copy look at it right there
and you get on itunes and all your local
bookstores and all that good stuff
you